[Music]
oil and gas industry started this
fracking boom
[Music]
and at first they were encroaching into
neighborhoods and into backyards not in
our backyard not in anyone's backyard
get the frack out of our lives
now their emissions their pollution that
they release from these sites is a
problem for everyone around the globe
because methane is a very powerful
greenhouse gas
the permian basin in texas
it's by far the most productive field in
the country i think more than half the
country's drill rigs were operating
there over the past few years
and sharon wilson goes out there every
couple months with this camera that can
see methane this invisible pollutant
if you could see the emissions with your
naked eye there never would have been a
fracking boom you cannot see it without
this camera
[Music]
[Applause]
if you think about the fossil fuels that
are down in the ground
one of the main ones is actually methane
and what we refer to as natural gas
is essentially a combination of gases
that come up from the ground that are
mostly methane with a few other gases
thrown in there
methane is a super powerful greenhouse
gas it has about 80 times the global
warming potential of carbon dioxide over
a 20-year period and scientists think
that about a quarter of all the
human-caused warming that we've
experienced to date is because of
methane emissions by humans
we do a lot of different things to put
methane in the atmosphere
raising livestock is a big contributor
growing rice is another one
landfills sewage there's all different
kinds of things
and then of course oil and gas
there's a new unconventional process for
extracting natural gas from shale
in the early 2000s there were these
combination of innovations in how we
drill for oil and gas we sometimes refer
to it as fracking we drill way way deep
past the water table as far as two miles
and we drill horizontally through that
shale
and one of the things that did was it
caused natural gas to be way more
abundant and cheap than it ever was
before we're pulling almost
three-quarters of a billion cubic feet
of natural gas a day fracking has
revolutionized the u.s energy market
natural gas if you burn it in a power
plant it emits about half the carbon of
coal
so that kind of looks like a real
positive for the environment the risk
with that is that we didn't really know
how much methane might be escaping prior
to being burned in a power plant so now
we know that the permian the basin as a
whole is emitting about 2.9 million
metric tons of methane a year
if you think about how much warming that
gas is causing it's about the same as
the entire state of florida all the
human-caused missions and you know one
of our most populous states
[Music]
i was curious about finding some of the
lowest hanging fruit in terms of climate
action
some of the things that the world is
going to have to do to
slow the pace of global warming are
difficult the methane problem in the oil
and gas industry
is relatively tractable it involves
essentially preserving something that
the industry is wasting that it could be
selling for money
so i went out to the permian basin in
may and i drove around for a few days
with sharon wilson
oh these guys are going to be pissed
because i am going to get out and
take a video of their site
[Music]
i'm a certified optical gas imaging
thermographer and a field advocate for
earthworks
i use an optical gas imaging camera it's
manufactured by flir which stands for
forward-looking infrared
it's 100 000
camera that uses infrared sensors to
produce an image that shows methane
i make visible the invisible emissions
out here to prove that the oil and gas
industry is not containing their methane
gas
i'm seeing a lot of emissions coming
from the tank valves
sometimes the industry will say that
steam
that's just an excuse industry makes
they use the same
camera that we use
they don't use it to go find steam
sharon was um
not really an environmentalist she used
to work for an oil services company back
in the day
and she had this beautiful place out in
the country she was raising her boys
there and
she really blamed fracking for
kind of ruining the air and water in her
area and so she became sort of mobilized
to do something about it
when my water turned black
no one came
because
if it has to do with oil and gas
no one's coming
you're on your own
so i didn't want
other people
to go through that
[Music]
we went out towards pecos texas which is
near the heart of where the oil boom has
been kind of happening in the last few
years
a lot of the permian is just miles and
miles away from a public road
and the roads are just kind of built by
the oil companies and off limits to the
public
and so there's a lot of kind of driving
around figuring out how to get places
oh yeah i don't see a sign that's no
trespassing
i don't know what do y'all think
all they can do is come at us on their
four-wheeler with raffle
i didn't know
whether we would find any methane
i mean
most of these emissions are evidence of
something going wrong
maybe we'd strike
out but you know sharon has done this a
lot she was pretty confident
and we found lots of events every day
methane it's just kind of everywhere
so we're out here in the permian basin
at night
we're not far from pecos texas
and across the street from us is a uh
is a well site
um and to the unaided eye it looks uh
pretty normal give you a look
now we'll show you what sharon wilson
sees through her
optical gas imaging camera
that's what the camera sees
is coming up from the top of the flare
an unlit flare
it's confounding because of course
natural gas is a useful fuel that people
pay money for it's not really in
anyone's interest to
waste it
but gas is very difficult to handle it's
it's hard to store it's hard to
transport it's easy for pressure to
build up somewhere and you have to
release it somehow
so in places like the permian basin you
see a lot of giant flares that are
burning natural gas
it sounds kind of like a jet engine
[Music]
if you burn the gas obviously that's not
great for the environment because you're
putting carbon dioxide into the air
but releasing it without burning it is
something like 16 times as bad because
then you're releasing methane rather
than carbon
when a flare goes out it just becomes a
big vent pipe
and it vents methane gas to the
atmosphere
we found leaks both from places she'd
been to before that were still
problematic and new places we just
stumbled across
there's pretty significant emissions
coming from the top
of this row of tanks that you see behind
me
volatile organic compounds and methane
gas
i wouldn't want to live downwind
uh so we put a lot of miles on today
drove around to a lot of sites
and uh
it turns out it's actually pretty easy
to find these emissions if you just look
around
this part of the country with a camera
that can see them
once we have the footage we
submit complaints to the tceq the texas
regulatory agency
i've made
over 240 complaints
and even if they take action it doesn't
last
but until something changes we'll keep
doing this
sharon has probably done more than
anyone else to kind of publicize the
problem in the permian
but sharon's work is
kind of scatter shot in a way because
her goal is to find problems and
publicize them a lot of other people out
there are focused on
what can we do
to clean it up
so environmental defense fund you could
think about what they're doing in the
permian is sort of like dispatching like
a thousand sharon wilson's hitting
hundreds and hundreds of sites in a
systematic way to try to put some kind
of scientific
credibility behind their findings so in
this case it potentially could be a
safety hazard in addition to so i went
to austin texas to visit david lyon
who's running edf's permian project
what have you found so far
we found that emissions in the permian
are very high
we find that about five percent of these
flares are unlit and venting all the
methane to the atmosphere and about
another five percent have combustion
problems
i i did expect some flares to be unlit
but
was shocked that consistently we're
finding at least five percent our unlit
inventing so showing that this is a
ubiquitous major problem in in the basin
what's the hope that you'll be able to
accomplish
so really we have two goals one is to
have the data inform regulators so they
can design effective policies we also
want to have actions by the operators in
the permian so they would make changes
to their sites which would
would minimize the occurrence of those
kinds of issues in the future
the industry is kind of under attack
from all sides right now
last year the french government
essentially vetoed a seven billion
dollar deal to import liquefied natural
gas from the permian because of concerns
about the greenhouse gas
profile
and that really sent a shockwave through
the energy industry
and at the same time these companies are
catching it from their investors and
lenders so wall street banks and asset
managers are really pushing these
companies to do something about their
emissions profile
if you look at what oil companies are
saying publicly they are
saying almost uniformly that they're
very focused on this problem we're wide
awake about the dangers of climate
change we put very stringent targets on
methane it's absolutely critical that we
as a company get this right and frankly
we as an industry get this right we are
ready to curb our emissions and we will
do it together
for a better and sustainable future
so bp they've been doing a lot to change
up how their whole infrastructure works
there to reduce the amount of methane
that they're leaking
reduce the amount of gas that they're
flaring they say that this changeover is
going to cost upwards of a billion
dollars but that it'll ultimately pay
for itself through additional sales of
gas
for oil and gas the the pollutant is the
product so that's one of the reasons
that edf focuses on oil and gas methane
emissions it's a win-win situation the
planet benefits from less greenhouse gas
emissions but at the same time the
operators benefit because they have more
efficient operations and can often sell
more product
[Music]
the industry is in a period of
retrenchment right now
there was just an absolute boom times a
few years ago when people were just
drilling like crazy
and that kind of rush contributed to the
scale of the waste and emissions that we
saw
the pandemic and lower oil prices have
slowed that down historic drop in crude
oil prices at one point the price fell
to a shocking negative 37 apparel and
even as prices now climb back up the
industry is sort of pledging not to go
crazy again
but in a few years
when the next boom happens either in the
permian or somewhere else and there's
real money to be made
are they going to show the same
restraint that they're pledging right
now
or are they going to focus on the short
term bottom line which is let's just
drill as fast as we can
and who cares if some methane leaks into
the
air people in the industry
often say that they're actually working
on this methane problem
uh does that make you feel better do you
feel like we're on the right track no
i've been hearing that for over a decade
now i've been hearing their promises for
over a decade
it's like
forgiving your cheating lover one more
time
[Music]
you